et euh nous nous réunissons cet
après-midi donc pour entendre Monsieur
Olivier best ministre délégué chargé du
Commerce extérieur de l'attractivité et
des Français de l'étranger et je le
salue et c'est pas la première fois
monsieur le ministre que vous venez dans
notre commission peut-être sur la
nouvelle mandature mais voilà cette
audition est captée diffusée sur le site
internet du Sénat je vous préviens elle
est ouverte aux membres du groupe de
suivi des accords commerciaux
internationaux qui viennent d'être
désignés par les trois commissions
compétentes mais euh je pense je ne sais
pas s'il y a eu l'information nécessaire
pour les prévenir les enjeux commerciaux
sont au cœur de l'actualité européenne
et ont connu ces dernières semaines des
développements que je qualifierai en D
de si la Commission européenne dans son
dernier programme de travail s'était
montré très très volontariste elle
n'atteindra clairement pas ses objectifs
certes deux accords commerciaux sont en
phase d'aboutissement celui conclut avec
la Nouvelle-Zélande le processus de
ratification au niveau de l'Union c'est
étant achevé le 27 novembre et les deux
accords avec le Chili dont la signature
devrait intervenir dans les prochains
jours monsieur le ministre en revanche
l'accord avec le Mexique n'a pas pu être
finalisé le projet d'accord avec
l'Australie qui semblait apportter deain
a été refusé par le Premier ministre
australien notamment en raison du volet
agricole que la France avait
probablement imposé quant à l'accord
avec le
mercosour en dépit des nombreuses
pressions exercées par la Commission
européenne par par la présidence
espatiale du conseil comme j'ai pu le
mesurer lors de la dernière COSAC avec
Didier Marie mais aussi Claude
Kerne mais aussi par notre voisin
allemand il n'aboutira pas demain vous
savez que le Sénat s'était montré très
vigilant et opposé à des concessions
attives pour
un obtention d'un accord à tout prix
nous constatons désormais que les
autorités argentines y compris le
gouvernement sortant ne veulent pas non
plus de cet accord cette séquence
interroge néanmoins sur la dynamique à
l'œuvre au niveau de l'Union européenne
ainsi que sur la manière dont les
États-membres et les parlements
nationaux sont associés au processus de
négociation des accords faisait l'objet
de notre discussion en apparta en
s'appuyant sur sa stratégie européenne
en matière de sécurité économique la
Commission européenne a voulu forcer la
main en cette fin de mandature en
mettant en avant les enjeux
géopolitiques voire géostratégiques
notamment pour sécuriser l'accès à
certains matériaux critiques pour les
transitions écologiques et numériques
nous crions nous nous ne nions pas ces
enjeux ni la stratégie de déploiement
agressive de de la Chine mais nous
considérons que nous devons affirmer
avec force les intérêts français qui ne
sont pas moins importants que les
intérêts espagnols ou allemands nous
serons donc heureux d'entendre votre
analyse de ces enjeux commerciaux
peut-être pourrez-vous nous rendre
compte des résultats du dernier conseil
commerce qui s'est tenu tout à fait
récemment la semaine dernière le 27
novembre au cours duquel outre le
calendrier de signature de l'accord avec
le Chili trois points importants ont été
évoqués premièrement la préparation de
la 13e Conférence ministérielle de
l'Organisation mondiale du commerce la
remise en ordre de marche de l'Organe
d'appel du mécanisme de règlement des
différents restant une priorité pour
l'Union européenne qui est certainement
le bloc le plus engagé en faveur de
multilatéralisme même si nous devons
prendre garde au procès en
protectionnisme vert qu'on voit monter
dans certains pays en développement et
que certains concurrents utilisent
contre nous deuxièmement les relations
commerciales entre l'Union et les
États-Unis l'acier et l'aluminium
demeurant des enjeux bien sûr majeur et
enfin les perspectives de négociation
des accords commerciaux alors que
plusieurs négociations sont encore
ouvertes notamment avec l'Inde au-delà
de ces thèmes déjà très substantiel je
veux également vous dire que nous
accordons une grande attention à la mise
en œuvre des outils de défense
commercial nous avons échangé à
plusieurs reprises avec Denis redonet le
direct directeur général adjoint de la
DG commerce qui va notamment piloter
l'enquête antiubvention concernant
l'industrie automobile électrique
chinoise vous pourrez nous faire part de
votre analyse sur ces enjeux nous avons
le sentiment que l'Union européenne est
réellement sortie d'une forme de naïveté
en en la matière mais manifestement des
progrès peuvent encore être réalisés
pour permettre aux petites et moyennes
entreprises qui n'appartiennent pas à
des fédérations puissantes et
structurées et ça monsieur don nous l'a
répété euh
elles ne peuvent pas faire valoir leur
leurs droits et défendre leurs intérêts
et quelquefois ne sont même pas informé
de leur capacité de recours monsieur le
ministre je vous cède la parole pour je
sais pas 10 15 minutes parole libre au
ministre mais pour permettre surtout à
nos à nos collègues de vous poser des
questions à
dooc bien merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les sénateur
d'abord merci de votre invitation euh
ici pour cette audition devant la la
Commission et euh surtout merci de me
donner l'occasion de revenir sur le
Conseil des Ministres de l'Union
européenne dédié au commerce qui a eu
lieu le 27 novembre dernier de refaire
un petit point sur l'ordre du jour et
euh bien sûr de de mettre une focale
particulière sur euh les accords
commerciaux alors d'abord euh vous dire
que ce conseil des ministres a commencé
euh par débattre de la position d' un
européenne et des États-membres lors de
la prochaine réunion de l'Organisation
mondiale du commerce réunion
ministérielle la
13e du nom qui se tiendra du 26 au 29
février prochain à Abou Dhabi alors vous
l'avez dit dans votre propos liminaire
monsieur le Président l'enjeu principale
de cette réunion portera notamment sur
la réforme des instituts de l'OMC
notamment le
déblocage de l'Organe d'appel de
l'Organe de règlement des différents
vous le savez cet organe est paralysé
maintenant depuis plusieurs années par
nos amis
américains qui ne nomme pas les
personnes qui devraient nommer pour
faire fonctionner cet organe et du coup
paralyse si vous
voulez la enfin le processus on va dire
de
règlement des litiges qui doit présider
au multilatéralisme que nous avons
établi dans le cadre de l'OMC je je dis
c'est important pour l'Union européenne
pourquoi parce que lorsqu'on regarde nos
échanges commerciaux on a quand même à
peu près plus de 40 % de nos échanges
commerciaux qui sont régis par les
règles de l'OMC et donc euh ne pas euh
pouvoir euh on va dire régler de
manière juridictionnelle les différents
que nous avons à travers ces organes de
l'OMC c'est évidemment euh fragiliser
les règles elles-mêmes et quelque part
remettre en cause la possibilité d'avoir
un multilatéralisme commercial et qui
dit absence de multilatéralisme dit
surtout retour à des comportements
unilat les comportements
unilatéraux peuvent évidemment être
fortement préjudiciables pas simplement
au commerce mais en
réalité à l'ensemble de notre
économie avec le retour de barrières
tarifaires de de barrières non
tarifaires qui au final ferait peser un
coût supplémentaire pour les
consommateurs et donc pourrait venir
entamer le pouvoir d'achat des
Françaises et des
Français c'est la raison pour laquelle
je me rendrai aussi la semaine prochaine
au au aux États-Unis pour discuter avec
nos amis américains euh des solutions
qu'ils peuvent mettre sur la table afin
de débloquer cet organe d'appel mais
au-delà nous discuterons aussi à Abu
Dhabi d'un certain nombre de secteurs
dans lesquels nous pouvons accroître
encore nos efforts en matière de
réglementation commerciale nous avions
lors de la 12e conférence l'année
dernière euh réussi à obtenir un peu à
l'arracher mais tout de même un accord
sur la pêche illégale sur les
subventions à la pêche illégale euh pour
remettre en question justement et
interdire les subventions aux pêches
illégales euh nous avons aujourd'hui
dans ce même domaine encore beaucoup de
de choses à faire y compris d'ailleurs
euh la mise en œuvre concrète de de cet
accord et l'élargissement aux
problématiques de la pêche euh y compris
des subventions à la pêche légale euh le
deuxème point que nous avons abordé ce
sont justement les relations avec les
États-Unis d'Amérique au-delà de la
question de l'organe de de règlement des
différents euh relation qui porte sur
deux contentieux que nous avons
maintenant
depuis plusieurs années notamment acier
aluminium depuis 2018 qui avait fait
l'objet en 2021 d'un accord
temporaire qui visait à suspendre les
droits de douane supplémentaires qui
avaient été imposé par les Américains et
également les mesures que l'Union
européenne avait pris en réponse à ces
droits de douane l'idée évidemment
serait de pouvoir aboutir à une solution
pérenne cette solution pérenne
aujourd'hui elle paraît compliquée
puisque lors du dernier sommet UE
États-Unis les Américains n'ont pas mis
sur la table de proposition qui
permettrai de pérénniser cette cet
accord nous avons des discussions qui
porte
essentiellement sur la la le nombre de
quotas d'acier dans un contexte qui
reste mondialement on le sait
excédentaire par rapport aux demandes
sur la production euh mais aussi euh aux
côas qui peuvent être faits par pays euh
donc il y a les qualités d'acier type
d'acier mais il a aussi les les pays
donc euh voilà nous nous sommes encore
en discussion la probabilité que nous
ayons un accord pérenne d'ici à la fin
de l'année est peu probable je ne vous
le cache pas euh même si les discussions
continuent euh nous devons donc tout
faire euh à minima pour proroger euh
l'accord temporaire qui a été est mise
en place nous auri évidemment souhaité
un accord permanent avant la fin de la
mandature de l'administration Biden euh
voilà avec un un règlement aussi de de
de la
question de la fameuse mesure
232 américaine mais cette hypothèse
estant peu probable nous serions à
minima
preneur d'une P enfin d'uneune
prolongation de l'accord temporaire pour
éviter de voir revenir les droits de
douane dont on sait que elles peuvent on
va dire handicaper un certain nombre de
nos de nos acteurs et surtout à travers
les mesures qui sont prises voilà de
part et d'autre en représaille des dites
mesures handicapé d'autres filières je
pense notamment à la filière des vins et
spiritueux
françaises qui est qui a été ciblé par
ces mesures euh en 2018 donc nous allons
tout faire pour préserver nos nos
filières d'un retour de de droit de
douanes supplémentair ou de contingents
supplémentaires euh sur euh nos filières
euh nous travaillons aussi en parallèle
même si euh là le délai est un peu moins
urgent sur le contentieux Airbus Boeing
euh en cherchant également une solution
pérenne euh à l'accord là aussi
temporaire que nous avons actuellement
avec les Américains euh nous avons
abordé un un 3e point lors de ce conseil
du 27 novembre qui est le rapport de la
Commission européenne sur la mise en
œuvre des accords commerciaux avec là
aussi des progrès qui ont été faits par
l'Union européenne avec la mise en place
d'un chief trade enforcement officer euh
qui vise justement à faire la suite de
la signature des accords et s'assurer
que ces accords soient bien mis en œuvre
que les barrières tarifaires euh soient
bien
démantelé conformément aux accords je
rappelle que chaque année pour nos
entreprises c'est un gain de 3 milliards
d'euros concrètement sur ces accords
commerciaux et nous mettons en place en
parallèle et cette fois-ci au niveau
national au niveau français c'est mise
en place par mon mon ministère avec bien
sûr le concours de la direction du
Trésor
ài un certain nombre d'événements pour
informer nos filières
euh notamment nos filières agricoles
pour qu'ell puissent euh on va dire
utiliser de la manière la plus optimale
possible ces accords commerciaux et donc
éviter de payer des droits de douane
qu'il ne devrai pas payer voilà le
niveau d'information est évidemment
essentiel et donc nous le faisons euh de
manière aujourd'hui très
dynamique même si j'en conviens il peut
encore y avoir des petites entreprises
qui ne savent pas suffisamment se servir
de ces accords commerciaux et c'est
aussi l'un des points que nous avons mis
dans le plan haoser l'export pour faire
en sorte que chaque entreprise ait la
capacité d'optimiser ces accords
commerciaux ce qui m'amène au dernier
point du Conseil du 27 novembre
justement les accords commerciaux vous
avez parlé monsieur le le
président des acccord sur la
Nouvelle-Zélande et notamment le Chili
donc la Nouvelle-Zélande a été la
décision de signature a été euh ratifié
par le Conseil des Ministres de l'Union
européenne la semaine dernière lors de
ce conseil du 27
novembre sur le Chili la décision de
signature a été validée par le conseil
sur les deux accords l'accord global et
l'accord
intérimaire hier euh euh voilà donc ce
sont deux accords qu'on peut considérer
comme étant aujourd'hui euh euh
définitifs euh et qui sont je le pense
largement favorables à la France euh et
notamment à nos filières agricoles sur
les vins et spiritueux sur les fromages
euh notamment en ce qui concerne la
Nouvelle-Zélande euh nous pourrons
discuter si vous le voulez euh de la
question de la viande ovine qui a été
l'un des sujets de crispation sur cet
accord Nouvelle-Zélande mais euh je
tiens à vous rassurer de la même manière
que j'ai rassuré les filières si vous
voulez la Nouvelle-Zélande a utilise cet
accord plus comme un accord on va dire
de précaution euh capable de dérisquer
des situations euh géopolitiques
compliquées avec certains des acteurs
qui sont aujourd'hui ses clients mais
euh aujourd'hui la Nouvelle-Zélande
l'utilise déjà pas la totalité de ces
contingents
OMC ils sont à moins de 70 % des
contingents OMC sur laavandeovine et
donc il est peu probable voilà que les
38000 tonnes équivalents carcasse qu'ils
avaient obtenu dans l'accord soit en
réalité
aujourd'hui réellement envoyé à
destination de l'Union européenne donc
il n'y a pas si vous voulez de péril
contrairement à ce que certains
pouvaient dire sur notre filière ovine
du fait de l'accord Nouvelle-Zélande sur
l'accord Chilia il est effectivement
très important pour nous d'un point de
vue
minérocritique puisque ça ne sert à rien
de vouloir construire des véhicules
électriques si on ne construit pas de
batterie ça ne sert à rien de construire
des batteries si on n'a pas accès à du
lithium or le Chili est l'un des
premiers producteurs mondials de lithium
avec l'une des premières réserves
mondial de lithium et donc nous avons
tout intérêt à nouer des accords euh
important avec le Chili c'est aussi la
raison pour laquelle d'ailleurs je me
suis rendu au Chili au mois de juin
dernier en ce qui concerne l'accord sur
l'Australie vous l'avez dit cet accord
n'a pas pu aboutir malgré les
discussions que nous avons eu en marge
du G7 à Osaka euh au mois de
euh d'octobre dernier
euh alors la la raison il y a plusieurs
raisons he il y avait aussi des
questions liées à l'industrie automobile
mais euh les Australiens nous
demandaient justement l'équivalent des
néozélandais sur la viande ovine il
voulent un quotat de 38000 tonnes
équivalent carcasse sur la viande ovin
ce qui pour le coup n'était pas possible
pourquoi parce que les Australiens sont
aujourd'hui en une situation de
surproduction euh au niveau de leur
filière auovin parce qu'ils ont perdu
des des marchés importants au
Moyen-Orient donc il traversent une une
crise de surproduction et si nous avions
ouvert de tels quotas contrairement à la
Nouvelle-Zélande nous pouvions être
certain que la viande ovine australienne
serait bien arrivé euh au sein de
l'Union européenne et là il s'agissait
euh voilà d'une d'une production qui
pouvait représenter près de 12 % de la
production européenne ça aurait mis euh
en péril nos filières et donc euh nous
avons été extrêmement ferm euh vis-à-vis
de nos amis australiens euh en disant
qu'il n'était pas possible pour nous euh
euh de euh d'accorder de tel de tel
quotas et je voudrais remercier aussi la
Commission européenne parce que la
Commission européenne nous a suivi sur
cette ligne de fermeté et elle a défendu
le secteur agricole français euh voilà
ce qui n'a pas permis de signer euh
l'accord euh voilà qui reviendra
peut-être un jour si les Australiens
acceptent euh un accord qui ne comporte
pas euh de telles demandes sur le
secteur agricole euh je tiens à préciser
que en ce qui concerne les euh euh les
standards environnementaux en revanche
nous avions un accord parfait avec avec
l'Australie ce qui n'est pas le cas et
c'est ma transition du mercosour je
rappelle que cet accord du mercosour
signé en 2019 négocié depuis 1999 donc
depuis plus de 20 ans euh avait fait
l'objet d'une remise en cause par la
France et d'autres pays de l'Union
européenne euh au motif que il ne
comportait pas la nouvelle approche que
nous souhaitions imposer aux accords
commerciaux c'est-à-dire remettre
l'humain et la planète au cœur de nos
accords l'idée est très simple c'est de
dire que nous sommes ouverts sur le
monde mais pas dans n'importe quellees
condition et que cette ouverture
nécessite une réciprocité et notamment
une adaptation sur les standards à la
fois en matière de droit du travail et
en matière de droit de l'environnement
qui sont ceux aujourd'hui en vigueur au
sein de l'Union européenne c'est donc
les conventions de l'OIT notamment sur
l'interdiction du travail forcé
l'interdiction du travail des enfants et
en matière environnementale les accords
de Paris comme clause essentielle c'est
veut dire que si à un moment ces accords
ne sont pas respectés ou que le pays en
sort cela fait tomber l'accord de
commerce euh
c'était la le règlement sur la
déforestation l'interdiction de la
déforestation que nous avons voté
l'année dernière au niveau de l'Union
européenne et euh également l'alignement
du chapitre commerce développement
durable sur les standards euh les plus
ambitieux de l'Union européenne avec la
possibilité de prendre des sanctions si
ces standards ne sont pas respectés par
les produits importés euh et nous avions
demander également des clauses miroires
pour faire en sorte que les normes
sanitaires environnementales qui sont
imposé
à nos propres producteurs je pense
notamment au secteur agricole soit
imposé également aux producteurs sur les
produits importés je je le dis parce que
on parle vous l'avez dit monsieur le
Président certain nombre de pays du Sud
disent qu'il s'agit d'une sorte de
néoimpérialisme c'estàdire d'imposer aux
autres des normes pour leurs propres
producteurs ce n'est absolument pas le
cas s'agit pas de dire tous les
producteurs brésiliens doivent demain
respecter les standards européens il
s'agit simplement de dire si vous voulez
importer des produits exporter des
produits dans l'Union européenne vous
devez
respecter les standards qui sont ceux de
l'Union européenne il nous paraît en
effet difficile d'imposer des standards
au demeurant toujours plus ambitieux à
nos propres producteurs et en même temps
de dire nous ouvrons nos marchés à des
gens qui ne respectent pas nos standards
c'est aussi une question d'ailleurs de
protection du consommateur lui-même euh
qui pourrait croire que certains
produits certaines pratiques sont
interdits et donc être en confiance avec
les produits qu'il trouveraient sur le
marché se retrouver le lendemain avec
des produits qui en réalité parce qu'ils
ne sont pas produits dans l'Union
européenne ne respecteraient absolument
pas ces standards donc euh nous avons
tenu bon sur cette position euh en
conformité d'ailleurs avec les
résolutions qui ont été votées à la fois
à l'Assemblée nationale et je crois au
au Sénat euh c'est une ligne de de
conduite que j'ai répété à chaque
conseil des ministres formel ou informel
de l'Union européenne avec un certain
nombre de nos pays partenaires
état-membres de l'Union européenne qui
partagent notre vision je dois dire
aussi qu'il y a des pays qui ne
partagent pas notre vision et qui
pensent que nous devons signer coûte que
coûte cet accord parce qu'il s'agit
aussi de dérisqué a des positions
industrielles euh prises notamment en
Chine et que donc c'était un accord qui
pouvait être important pour leur propre
industrie évidemment nous le comprenons
d'ailleurs nous soutenons si vous voulez
l'industrie de ces pays et nous
souhaitons évidemment que il puisse
trouver de nouveaux marchés mais ça ne
peut pas se faire au détriment de nos
propres intérêts et surtout de nos
propres standards des propres ambitions
que l'Union européenne porte elle-même
avec ses États-membres en matière
environnementale comme les accords de
Paris la lutte contre la déforestation
euh ou
encore le bien-être animal euh ce qui
évidemment est était des sujets on va
dire sensibles pour ne pas dire majeur
dans le cadre des des discussions
mercosour voilà euh les Argentins
euh ont fait savoir qu'il n'était pas
prêt également à signer ce ce traité
donc aujourd'hui euh ce traité n'est pas
signé ne sera pas signé quel sera son
avenir euh aujourd'hui nul ne le sait il
y a je pense euh deux
positions on va dire non convergentes il
y a celle à l'intérieur même du
mercosour où les États ne sont pas
nécessairement d'accord entre eux sur la
manière de traiter la position de
l'Union européenne et au sein de l'Union
européenne quand bien même d'ailleurs le
traité serait signé par la Commission
européenne il ne serait pas
nécessairement ratifié par
ces États-membres puisque nous ne ne
sommes pas aujourd'hui en tout cas la la
France a été clair en l'état actuel des
discussions ce traité n'était pas
acceptable voilà si vous voulez ce qu'on
peut dire
sur les gros sujets il y a des
discussions qui se poursuivent sur
l'Inde avec je
pense un sujet qui est qui est
évidemment
on va dire sensible enfin il y a deux
sujets sensibles le premier évidemment
c'est la même question
environnementale voilà les même les
mêmes standards compliqué
évidemment pour les Indiens de répondre
totalement à ce niveau de standard et
nous avons des discussions compliquées
également avec nos amis Indias sur
l'application des engagements fédéraux
au niveau des États fédérés puisque les
les Indiens nous disent nous sommes un
état fédéral donc nous pouvons nous
engager en ce qui concerne les les les
les les états enfin l'État fédéral mais
nous ne pouvons pas nous engager pour
les États fédérés bon ce qui évidemment
est compliqué parce que ça reviendrait à
dire par exemple sur les marchés publics
que en réciprocité euh les Indiens
seraient éligibles aux marchés publics
qui sont faits par la Commission
européenne mais qu'il faudrait ensuite
négocier avec les 27 états- membres
individuellement de de de l'Union pour
chacun de leur marchés ce qui évidemment
est est totalement totalement impossible
et infaisable et donc n nous sommes dans
dans des discussions de ce registre euh
avec nos amis indien nous verrons alors
il y a on va dire il y a moins d'intérêt
stratégique sur le plan agricole pour la
pour la France donc c'est un sujet on va
dire un peu moins sensible que ne
pouvait l'être le mercosour mais nous
sommes très vigilants également dans le
dans le suivi de ces de ces négociations
voilà Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs rapidement euh voilà en ayant
conscience déjà d'AV ir été long mais
euh de manière synthétique ce que nous
pouvions dire je suis évidemment à votre
entière disposition pour répondre à à
toutes vos questions et je suis sûr que
ces questions je ne voulais pas
préampter porteront peut-être aussi sur
le CTA voilà qui est un un sujet je sais
sensible au sein de votre Haute
Assemblée merci Monsieur le Ministre
oui pour reprendre devant les collègues
avant de leur donner leur donner la
parole bien sûr euh une question
toujours sur le sur le mercosour bien
sûr nous garderons vigilance parce que
euh pour l'instant effectivement les
Argentins entre guillemets nous sauvent
la mise euh mais comme je vous le disais
je pense que le le président argentin
malgré la sortie avec sa tronçonneuse
sera vite rendu aux réalité mondial et
au réalité aussi de l'Amérique du Sud
euh et et reviendra peut-être un certain
un moment beaucoup plus calme à à la
charge avec les Brésiliens et et donc
nous devons être assez vigilant sur la
question deuxièmement vous nous
rassurez je dirais par rapport au fait
de la ratification par les parlements
parce queon avait une grande incertitude
Alain CADC je me souviens avait posé une
question sur le sujet disant que la
Commission était en train de nous
faire la le la procédure à l'envers en
fait permettant un passage en
avec un accord intérimaire sans passage
par la ratification et ça c'était quand
même quelque chose
de d'assz d'assez insupportable et
d'ailleurs la question la semaine
dernière porté aussi là-dessus disant la
première ministre on a besoin d'une
ratification par le Parlement parce que
voilà bien on va passer aux questions
alors j'ai Didier Marie
d'abord merci monsieur le ministre merci
monsieur le Président euh tout d'abord
peut-être une question sur la la
stratégie globale en en l'illustrant
avec
euh l'accord sur la Nouvelle-Zélande euh
comment Monsieur le Ministre arrivé
aujourd'hui à concilier la dimension
géopolitique des accords commerciaux la
sécurisation de nos approvisionnements
en matières premières
critique en composant diverses et euh
parallèlement le respect des exigences
climatiques j'ai bien entendu votre
argumentaire sur le mercosour que je
partage nous ne pouvons ratifier cet
accord dans les termes qui nous sont
présentés mais est-ce que aujourd'hui
l'on peut considérer que l'accord avec
la Nouvelle-Zélande
aussi positif soit-il en tout cas
présenté par la Commission
européenne est-ce que cet accord est
tout tout à fait compatible avec ce que
nous disons ce que vous dites sachant
que nous passons un accord avec un pays
qui est à 20000 km de l'Union européenne
qu'il porte en partie sur une dimension
agricole
avec la production de gaz à effet de
serre bien connu méthane et protoy
d'azote
et que on cherche à
lifier les échanges alors qu'il en
existe déjà dans le cadre de l'OMC donc
ma ma question ne se veut pas maline
mais comment arriver à concilier ce qui
pourrait apparaître comme un paradoxe
c'est-à-dire oui on a besoin d'accords
commerciaux notamment dans leur
dimension géostratégique et en même
temps chacun des accords commerciaux
peut générer une
détérioration du du climat notamment
sans parler des autres aspects et donc
ma question est simple ne faudrait-il
pas aujourd'hui réviser totalement la
doctrine de l'union de l'Union
européenne en matière de d'accords
commerciaux j'aurais si vous le
permettez euh deux autres questions la
première qui euh revient à ce qui a été
évoqué précédemment à savoir la place
des parlements nationaux dans euh ces
accords
euh on sait que euh la Commission
a la priorité parce que elle a la
compétence économique et commerciale et
quand il n'y a pas de dimension
politique dans les accords les
parlements nationaux ne sont pas
associés mais ceci pose évidemment un un
un problème et pour ce qui concerne le
CTA il y a eu un accord provisoire qui
reste provisoire depuis maintenant déjà
un certain temps et ici au Sénat alors
que nous auriionons dû le ratifier nous
ne l'avons toujours pas fait euh donc à
quel moment est-ce que le gouvernement
saisira le Sénat pour la ratification du
CTA enfin et c'est le dernier point qui
n'a pas grand-chose à voir avec ce que N
vient d'évoquer tout de suite mais qui
concerne votre portefeuille j'ai été
amené avec plusieurs collègues à vous
solliciter sur la mise en œuvre du
devoir de
vigilance et donc vous nous avez répondu
de façon extrêmement détaillé ceci étant
il me semble qu'il reste quelques points
euh en en en suspend notamment j'aurais
aimé avoir la position du Gouvernement
sur le seuil du nombre de salariés des
entreprises qui seront concernées par la
mise en œuvre de ce devoir de vigilance
et d'autre
part
sur l'ensemble des du périmètre est-ce
que les entreprises secteur financier
seront oui ou non concerné par la mise
en œuvre de de vigilance je vous
remercie merci Alain Cadec et se prépare
Louis voger et on fera par trois
monsieur oui alors Monsieur le Ministre
merci monsieur le Président d'abord je
partage l'essentiel de ce que vient de
dire mon collègue Didier Marie alors
c'est vrai que depuis euh quelques mois
quelques années euh la Commission fait
feu de tout bois hein le commissaire
Dombrovskis on connaît son son appétence
pour l'ultralibéralisme pour le libre
échange et donc euh c'est pas lui faire
offense que de lui dire c'est pas un
choix que je partage mais en tous les
cas
il a il a comme on dit 1000 paquets
alors Didier Marie évoqué tout de suite
le
mercosour il semblerait je sais pas
quelle est votre vision là-dessus il
semblerait que le chancelier schols et
le président
Loula veuilleent une ratification rapide
du mercosour enfin vous le savez
sûrement mieux que moi et qui qui font
pression j'imagine auprès de vous auprès
de des partenaires d'une manière ou
d'une autre en tous les cas pour pour
essayer de de de valider cet accord
alors quelle est la position de la
France précisément par rapport à à à C
ces éventuelles pressions de la part du
chanselier schols et et et du président
Loula mais une fois de plus
euh alors c'est une expression qu'on a
employé plusieurs fois tout à l'heure
évidemment qui est un peu trivial mais
on peut se demander si les Allemands
sont pas encore en train de nous la
faire à l'envers pardonnez-moi non non
mais il y a pas que là hein donc j'ai
été député européen pendant 10 ans je
sais ce que c'est hein
euh
par ailleurs le Chili je partage votre
pour l'avoir analysé je partage votre
analyse je pense que c'est ce sera un
bon accord et en tous les cas un accord
intéressant pour l'Union européenne et
pour la France en particulier maintenant
faut quand même être vigilant mais je
pense que ce sera un bon accord alors
sur la Nouvelle-Zélande je partage aussi
le les inquiétudes de mon de mon ami
Didier parce que alors c'est vrai qu'on
a essayé de mettre tout ce qu'il fallait
pour de limiter un certain nombre de
choses euh
de mettre des des des des des barrières
en quelque sorte mais c'est vrai que
notre filière agricole vous le savez est
très inquiète même si les quantités sont
précisées et et
donc qu'est-ce que vous répondez vous
aux craintes justement de de de la
filière agricole sur sur cet accord avec
avec la Nouvelle-Zélande qui fait peur
qui fait peur très clairement alors on a
l'accord avec le Mexique qui aujourd'hui
est en plus ou moins en standby en
quelque sorte euh c'est ce que vous nous
avez dit tout à l'heure et je partage
euh mais euh il faut il va falloir le
moderniser parce que il a il a quand
même déjà euh un certain âge entre
guillemets et et je voudrais savoir dans
quel dans quel sens vous souhaitez euh
vraiment le le le le le le moderniser et
puis euh et puis pour pour terminer
c'est vrai qu'on l'a évoqué rapidement
mais j'étais encore parlementaire
européen à ce moment-là au moment du CA
euh c'est vrai que ça fait 6 ans qu'on
est en en en période de transition en
quelque sorte c'està-dire que la la
Commission fait ce qu'elle veut depuis 6
ans et et aucun Parlement des 27 pays
pour l'instant n'a ratifié ce traité euh
et me semble-t-il il y a pas vraiment
beaucoup d'obligation à le à à le
ratifier aujourd'hui la Commission peut
l'imposer tant qu'elle veut alors quelle
va être la position de la France est-ce
que la France va faire confiance à enfin
va faire confiance va interroger son
parlement le Sénat et l'Assemblée
nationale pour ratifier cet accord ou
pas sachant qu'il y a 27 pays évidemment
il y a 27 partenaires
donc et cet accord a quand même quelques
trous dans la raquette donc bon pourra
évoquer bien d'autres bien d'autres
accords commerciaux
mais moi je pense que depuis que notre
ancien collègue monsieur Timmermans a
quitté la Commission européenne ça va
aller un peu mieux parce que comme
ultralibéral on fait pas mieux pas plus
vous le savez aussi bien que moi donc
voilà
merci merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre merci pour les
informations très précise que que vous
nous avez donné alors ma question est un
peu plus
franco-française le le bon
positionnement de notre pays dans
l'accueil des projets d'investissement
et aujourd'hui régulièrement souligné
notamment au sommet chous France et
cetera alors il y a les grandes annonces
gigafactory Vallé de la batterie dans le
Nord dans dans le nord du pays mais ma
ma question est la suivante et les
territoires les départements ruraux
comment peuvent-ils faire comment
qu'est-ce que quelle est votre politique
pour leur permettre à eux aussi
d'accéder à cette attractivité
renouvelée
voilà bien merci beaucoup euh messieurs
les sénateurs pour ces questions
monsieur le Président alors euh je je
vais commencer par
répondre sénateur
Marie sur la Nouvelle-Zélande avec la
question de la distance
bon c'est vrai qu'on peut se dire
pourquoi est-ce qu'on va faire des
accords commerciaux avec des pays qui
sont loin mais
enfin le but du commerce à un moment ou
un autre c'est et chacun le sait la
question des avantages
comparatifs ce qui a fondé le commerce
euh pas moderne mais déjà dans
l'antiquité euh et euh à un moment ou un
autre quand il y a des avantages
comparatifs il y a aussi la réciprocité
de l'ouverture bon alors vous allez dire
pourquoi est-ce qu'on va av va importer
de la poudre de lait des kiwi ou je ne
sais quoi de
Nouvelle-Zélande alors que nous
pourrions peut-être en avoir des plus
proches
dans le sens
inverse pourquoi exporter des
Airbus en Nouvelle-Zélande alors qu'ils
sont produits en
France pardon de quoi d'exporter des
Airbus ouis non mais vous voyez ce que
je veux dire c'estd que derrière
derrière ce raisonnement il y a en fait
un autre raisonnement qui est celui du
localisme c'est de dire que il faudrait
tout produire d'un point de vue local et
cetera ce qui évidemment est pas
possible si chaque pays se se met à à
produire ses avions et cetera on sait
que à la fin on a un modèle qui ne
tiendra pas debout parce qu'il y aura
pas la masse critique il y aura pas les
dépens technologique nécessairire et
cetera donc c'est un appauvrissement
global bon donc nous faisons du
commerce et c'est c'est le cas avec les
pays à peu près sur toute la planète
l'Australie est un tout petit peu plus
proche que la Nouvelle-Zélande enfin ça
se joue quelques quelques milliers de
kilomètres à peine donc voilà si vous
voulez moi je considère que s'interdire
de faire du commerce et là encore on
parle d'accord commerciaux parce qu' du
commerce qui se fait de toute façon hors
accords commerciaux mais s'interdire de
faire du commerce avec un pays au
prétexte qu'il est loin c'est se mettre
nous-même dans la difficulté c'est qu'on
va supprimer des emplois sur nos propres
territoires parce qu'on en verra pas de
je rappelle qu'avec la Nouvelle-Zélande
on est excédentaire il y a pas
énormément de pays où on a un excédent
commercial bon la Nouvelle-Zélande on a
un excédent commercial bon donc ça veut
dire que si on interdit de faire du
commerce avec la Nouvelle-Zélande grosso
modo on appauvrit notre pays et on va
derrière détruire des emplois chez nous
moi ma conviction parce que j'entends la
question du bilan carbone qui est
parfaitement légitime c'est dire on met
des accords de Paris dans un accord
commercial et de l'autre côté on fait du
commerce qui effidtivement va créer du
carbone bon le vrai sujet c'est ça c'est
qu'il faut des carboner les moyens de
transport il faut décarboner à la fois
la navigation le le le fret les cargot
et le fret aéien c'est ça le sujet bon
et nous y travaillons nous y travaillons
avec France 2030 j'étais encore il y a
il y a quelques semaines à saint-nazer
sur les chantiers de l'Atlantique où on
fait maintenant on est en train de de de
de mettre en place des études avec des
prototypes pour des bateaux véliques
hein avec des des voiles gigantesques
qui permettront demain de ne plus être
sur des moteurs diesel et cetera on a
des
moteurs JNL et cetera donc je pense que
la vrai sujet la vraie solution elle est
là
bon deè deè question la doctrine de
l'Union européenne sur les accords
commerciaux bon moi je vous donne mon
sentiment mon sentiment c'est que ça
sera de plus en plus compliqué d'avoir
des accords
globaux pourquoi parce que on le voit
bien avec un certain nombre de
pays si vous voulez mettre tous les pays
du monde sur nos standards du jour au
lendemain ça ne marchera pas bon
euh donc et en même temps se priver des
capacité de de de commerce sur un
certain nombre de secteurs on parlait
tout à l'heure des minéux critiques qui
sont indispensables à notre propre
transition énergétique c'est également
se mettre dans la difficulté bon donc
moi je pense que l'avenir est davantage
à des accords sectoriels hein euh pays
par pays sur les matières sur lesquelles
il y a un intérêt mutuel stratégique
convergent à à faire du commerce bon euh
on verra si c'est une approche qui est
partagée au niveau de la de la
Commission européenne et de nos
partenaires sur la question du CTA et de
la ratification
euh bon je je rappelle que normalement
lorsqu'un accord est commercial la
compétence est exclusivement à l'Union
européenne parce que c'est ainsi que
nous l'avons transféré y compris
d'ailleurs par référendum au moment du
du traité de riche lorsque c'est un
export mixte on a politique
investissement en plus du commercial la
compétence est partagée et le côté et le
côté justement politique et
investissement et ramené au niveau des
parlements nationaux qui ne sont pas 27
qui sont 47 je vrais pas dire de bêtises
mais je crois 47 parce que nous
rajoutons les parlements fédérés qui a
notamment en Allemagne et en
Belgique ce qui rajoute évidemment un
certain nombre de de d'assemblée bon
euh moi je suis je vous le dis très
favorable l'Assemblée nationale a déjà
ratifié le CTA moi je suis très très
favorable à ce qu'on puisse avoir cette
discussion ici au Sénat pourquoi parce
que maintenant on a 5 ans d'application
du CTA 6 ans presque au moins 5 ans
bientôt 6 ans et nous avons les
chiffres et nous savons aujourd'hui que
le cat l'application d'ailleurs les
Canadiens parfois s'en plaignent euh est
très favorable à la France et que
partout les chiffres voilà quand on
regarde globalement hein c'est plus 37 %
d'exportation en plus euh pour la France
avec des exportations notamment sur le
textile les chaussures plus 95 % du fait
de l'abaissement des des droits de
douanes les produits chimiques et les
cosmétiques plus 61 % et même sur la
filière euh agricole on a plus 40 %
d'exportation euh et la catastrophe
qu'on nous avait prédit rappelez-vous
sur le bœuf n'est pas arrivé on exporte
trois fois plus de bœuf français au
Canada qu'on importe de bœuf canadien en
France voilà donc euh on on a si vous
voulez aujourd'hui des des chiffres en
plus ce sont des montants qui sont
extrêmement extrêmement faibles c'est
quelques centaines de tonnes par rapport
au 1,5 million de tonnes que nous
produisons qu'
en en
France voilà donc on on a aujourd'hui
des des des chiffres qui montrent que ce
traité finalement est un bon traité et
qu'il est favorable à la France et donc
je pense que si nous en convenons
globalement nous avons intérêt
évidemment à le ratifier je pense que
nous avons intérêt à le ratifier aussi
pour envoyer un signal à la Commission
européenne en disant vous pouvez faire
confiance aux parlements nationaux parce
que lorsque le traité est bon
nous savons le ratifier par contre
évidemment quand le traité est mauvais
et qu'il porte atteinte à nos intérêts
évidemment nous disons non c'est sûr que
si on est dans une attitude en disant de
toute façon quel que soit le traité que
vous nous envoyé par principe on est
contre on est certain que la Commission
européenne trouvera toutes les procédur
possi pour finalement on va c'està dire
contourner les parlements nationaux
voilà donc moi je pense qu'on a intérêt
je vous dis comme ça mais à le faire
surtout qu' sait maintenant que c'est un
un bon
traité sur le devoir de vigilance alors
je je vais rapidement parce que il y a
toutes les autres questions
encore le mandat du conseil donc les
seuls proposés c'est 500 salariés pour
un chiffre d'affaires net mondial de 150
millions et les seuils sont abaissés
pour les secteurs à fort impact à 250
salariés et euh 40 millions les secteurs
en question sont l'agriculture le
textile
euh voilà euh pour
euh pour la finance
euh pour la finance la position de la
France elle est elle est très simple
c'est que nous ne souhaitons pas euh que
alors on na pas dit qu'il fallait
exclure le service le secteur de la
finance on a dit qu'il fallait exclure
la question des clients du secteur de de
la finance parce que ça nous semble
quasi impossible si vous voulez pas
d'ailleurs seulement pour le secteur de
la finance mais pour les tous les autres
secteurs c'est compliqué de monitorer
ses fournisseurs mais monitorer ses
clients si vous voulez ça fait peser sur
une entreprise des contraintes que
matériellement elles n'ont pas les
moyens d'exercer bon donc il faut quand
même qu'on soit pragmatique et et
réaliste et c'est c'est la position de
la France
monsieur le sénateur
cadek alors la position de la France sur
la volonté du chancelier schols et du
président Loula d'essayer de de d'aller
jusqu'au bout et de faire néanmoins
aboutir ce traité bon si vous voulez
euh nous on a exprimé notre position
notre position c'est que nous ne
soutiendrons pas un trait
qui ne répond pas aux conditions que
nous avons
posé c'est ça bon d'ailleurs l'Argentine
aurait été pour ça n'aurait rien changé
à la position de la France position de
la France a été claire on l'exprime de
manière clair partout et tout le temps
et moi je suis allé la porter j'étais
deux fois au Brésil cette année voilà et
j'ai dit à nos amis brésilien la même
chose que je vous dis à vous la même
chose que j'ai dit aux Allemands la même
chose que j'ai dit voilà aux uruguïen et
cetera voilà notre position bon
euh j'entends au
demeurant la sollicitation de
l'industrie allemande voilà et en tant
qu'Européen je suis sensible à ce sujet
et je pense que à un moment ou un autre
il faut qu'on trouve les moyens voilà de
répondre à cette question légitime de
drisking de l'industrie allemande voilà
si ça ne peut pas se faire par un accord
global alors regardons si on peut avoir
d'autres types de
possibilités voilà vis-à-vis de de
l'industrie allemande mais je pense
qu'il faut qu'on soit évidemment
attentif à ce ce sujet et comme je
remercie nos amis allemand d'être
sensible aux problématiques agricoles
françaises je suis également sensible
aux problématique industrielle et
notamment automobile allemande
euh et je pense que nous partageons tout
de même avec nos amis allemands la même
préoccupation sur les standards
environnementaux voilà et que donc nous
ne pouvons pas imaginer un compromis qui
fasse table ras complètement des
questions de déforestation d'accord de
Paris et cetera juste pour avoir un
accord qui ne serait pas compris et pas
accepté au niveau européen
euh vous avez parlé de la nouvelle éante
sur les craintes des filières agricoles
je pense y avoir répondu précédemment
notamment sur la question des quotas OMC
qui ne sont pas remplis donc que la
probabilité qu' les quotas soit ouvert
par le traité soi rempl me me semble peu
probable au demeurant on voit bien les
intérêts stratégiques de nos filières
notamment sur les vins les spiritueux
les fromages et cetera les céréales qui
je pense feront de l'accord
Nouvelle-Zélande comme on l'a eu avec le
CTA un accord qui sera positif pour
notre pays y compris pour les filières
agricoles et c'est ce que je dis
d'ailleurs aux filières lorsque je les
rencontre je comprends évidemment les
craintes qu'elles peuvent avoir quand
ell voit les les volumes et je les
rassure aussi en leur disant que
lorsque il faut dire non nous savons
dire non c'est ce que nous avons fait
notamment vis-à-vis de l'Australie
voilà alors il faut savoir dire non et
pouvoir dire non voilà c'est ce que nous
avons fait
enfin non seulement on a su dire non
mais on a pu dire non voilà les yeux
dans les yeux avec Don Farel le ministre
du Commerce que australien que
j'apprécie beaucoup au demeurant mais
voilà je dit je ne peux pas accepter ce
type de de quota parce que je ne veux
pas mettre en péril la filière auovines
française les accords sur le Mexique ben
les accord sur le Mexique pour l'instant
si vous voulez il faut déjà qu'il y a
une équipe mexicaine qui revienne à la
table avec des des des propositions ce
qui pour l'instant n'est pas le cas donc
nous en reparlerons
lorsque euh ce le le moment sera venu
euh sur le cage je vous ai répondu sur
les parlements voilà à travers la
réponse au sénateur Mariia monsieur le
sénateur Vogel en ce qui concerne
l'attractivité c'est vrai que c'est un
un autre volet évidemment de euh notre
notre ouverture euh commercial
euh nous avons la chance euh qui n'est
quand même pas tout à fait un hasard qui
est le fruit des des des réformes faites
aussi par cette majorité depuis
maintenant 6 ans d'être depuis 4 ans le
pays le plus attractif d'Europe
c'estàdire que chaque année on accueille
à peu près
170050 projets d'investissement étranger
souvent ce sont des extensions d'usine
parfois ce sont des créations d'usine
également de de plein pied euh on fait
un peu moins de Greenfield comme on dit
que certains de nos partenaires parce
que bah il y a le fameux zéro
artificiation des sols he et que donc
c'est compliqué de trouver le foncier
pour faire de nouvelles usines on va pas
se se le se mentir non plus donc il y a
beaucoup d'extensions mais aussi des
créations ex Nilo hein voilà euh alors
vous avez raison de porter une attention
à l'équilibre territorial de ces
implantations bon euh et je peux vous
dire que aujourd'hui la moitié des
projets un sur de est en destination des
territoires ruraux un sur de bon
euh rurau ou périurbain en tout cas des
des territoires qui font moins de de
200000 habitants euh nous avons alors je
je je vous donne juste pour lors du
dernier sommet chous France on avait 28
grandes annonces hein sur ces 28 grandes
annonces qui au total font 13 milliards
d'euros d'investissement 8000 créations
d' emploi ça correspond concrètement à
des projets qui vont à sargemine à grond
à fécan à anoné à bourbonlancy à
Rambouillet à Bussac à Marnet à la
chaussée Saint-Victor à laagnon à
Honfleur voilà donc si vous voulez ce
sont des exemples très précis très
concrets euh voilà nous avons des
exemples plus récents avec noouveau
nordisque qui a annoncé c'était la
semaine dernière 2 1 milliard d'euros
d'investissement qui sont créés cette
fois-ci dans la
commune de Ch voilà commune d'environ
40000 habitants donc je pense que c'est
important en tout cas je peux vous dire
que moi j'y veille d'une manière très
scrupuleuse parce que je pense que ça
répond à la fois la nécessité de
réindustrialiser les territoires ruraux
et ça répond aussi au sentiment de
fracture qui anime notre pays en donnant
l'impression en tout cas c'était ce qui
exprimait aussi le mouvement des gilets
jaunes que finalement il y avait les
grandes métropoles qui étaient sorties
gagnantes de la mondialisation pardon et
que les territoires ruraux ou
périurbains avaiit plutôt euh été laissé
en marge de de ce mouvement donc il est
très important que l'attractivité la
réindustrialisation de notre pays la
création d'activités se fasse à
destination de ces territoires voilà
pour ces trois premières questions
question merci on repart donc sur une
série Mathilde Olivier et Olivier et qui
se
prépare merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre j'avais une
question qui qui était un petit peu
similaire à celle de de Didier Marie
autour
du du paradoxe d'aujourd'hui signer des
accords commerciaux avec avec des pays
qui sont à l'autre bout de la planète et
qui et qui finalement sont en des
accords en ne sont pas alignés avec nos
objectifs de réduction de de nos
émissions de de gaz à effet de serre et
du coup revenir peut-être un petit peu
sur votre réponse qui opposait un petit
peu d'un côté les avantages comparatifs
et de l'autre le le l'idée de du du
localisme et je pense que il y a un
juste milieu entre les entre les
deux l'objectif c'est pas d'interdire le
commerce avec la Nouvelle-Zélande mais
mais de réfléchir à à comment
aujourd'hui dans notre économie mondiale
et bien on ne n'aggrave pas les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre et je
pense que c'est pas forcément la
technologie qui nous permettra de
répondre à cette à cette réduction ou en
tout cas notre objectif c'est que la
technologie nous permette de réduire nos
émissions de gaz effet de serre et pas
de compenser les émissions
supplémentaires que des que des que des
accords commerciaux
créeraii mais si vous voulez
éventuellement réagir là-dessus et puis
peut-être nous indiquer globalement en
terme d'accords commerciaux est-ce que
vous vous avez des réflexions une
politique de de de de réflexion autour
de comment on va faire évoluer nos nos
accords commerciaux sur le moyen terme
pour répondre à nos objectifs français
de réduction de de de nos émissions de
gaz à effet de serre après une question
un petit peu plus précise j'ai vu que il
y avait aussi eu un accord en lien avec
horizon Europe qui avait été signé dans
la même lignée que l'accord commercial
avec la Nouvelle-Zélande je me demandais
s'il y avait un un lien en fait entre
les accords
commerciaux avec la Nouvelle-Zélande et
cet accord qui a été qui a été signé sur
le programme Horizon Europe au niveau
européen et puis et puis revenir sur la
réforme de l'OMC dont vous avez dont
vous avez parlé en en début de en début
de d'exposé il me semble que j'avais vu
que que les objectifs
en lors de la rentrée était d'essayer
d'arriver à à à à des des avancé voir un
accord d'ici février 2024 à Abu Dhabi
est-ce que est-ce que vous pouvez nous
faire un point quels sont les éléments
de blocage
actuellement pour avancer vers cet
accord que ce soit sur l'Organe de
règlement des différents et puis
peut-être nous faire un point aussi sur
l'inclusion des objectifs de
développement durable dans la réforme de
l'OMC parce qu'il me semble que c'est
aussi aussi un sujet merci
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre merci pour la qualité des
des échanges hein je TS qu'on on va au
fond des des sujets bon le
multiatéralisme est en crise on l'entend
un peu partout peut-être encore plus
encore dans le domaine du de commerce et
alors donc se pose la question d'accords
commerciaux bilatéraux ou ou plus
régionaux mais alors se pose la question
des des choix
géostratégiques parce que à ce moment-là
on peut plus être présent partout et et
donc évidemment on vous demande beaucoup
d'éclairage en une seule en une seule
réunion mais enfin tout de même voyez il
y avait lundi c'est c'est c'est ça tombe
bien un colloque qui est organisé ici au
Sénat par business France sur l'azéane
l'Asie du
Sud-Est région du monde coincée et on
voit bien qu'il veulent ouvrir les taux
entre la la Chine et l'Inde et donc il
sont très Friant de d'accords
commerciaux avec l'Europe et et avec la
France je un exemple en tant que
président du groupe d'hamitié d'Asie du
Sud-Est nouveau je m'intéresse à à cette
question d'ailleurs pour faire sourire
au fond ils sont aussi friants de
d'échange technologique en nous disant
bah si on fait des échanges
technologiques d'ailleurs c'est rigolo
comment il nous voit hein parce que on
ouvrira nos marchés au vin et spiritueux
comme si il nous voit avec la la
baguette et le beret un peu Auel quelque
sorte tout de même euh remarquable après
la Coupe du monde de rugby et et ce
qu'on a montré c'est pas si étonnant
mais enfin tout de même euh voilà je je
donc quelle est notre réflexion parce
qu'à ce moment-là si le monde n'est plus
multilatéral il est évident qu'il va
falloir euh cibler faire des choix et et
et comment on va choisir ça euh quel le
rôle d'ailleurs des parlements par
rapport à cette grande question des des
intérêts géostratégiques de de de
l'Europe et de la France je vous
remercie
oui merci Président Monsieur le le
ministre euh alors que le le le déficit
du commerce extérieur de la France n'
n'a cessé de progresser ces ces
dernières années euh et que on entend
ici ou là des industriels qui qui
semblent particulièrement intéressés à
ce que à ce que les Américains font
notamment au titre de de l'IRA euh à la
fois sous forme d'aide et aussi
d'énergie pas chère qu'est-ce que vous
comptez faire
pour pour éviter que que certaines de
entreprises choisissent de s'installer
ailleurs bien merci beaucoup madames
messieurs les
sénateurs pour ces trois questions alors
d'abord pour madame la sénatrice
Olivier les circuits courts nous nous y
sommes totalement favorables si vous
voulez le
gouvernement encourage les les circuits
courts partout où on peut le faire après
il y a des produits qui ne viennent pas
nécessairement en circuit court et que
l'on continue d'ailleurs à consommer
d'un point de vue on va dire je v dire
quotidien enfin on a pris l'habitude de
manger des bananes si vous voulez à peu
près quel que soit les les périodes de
l'année et les bananes ne poussent pas
en en métropole on les fait venir
généralement d'ailleurs soit de nos
territoires d'outrem soit d'autres
d'autres pays bon je suis pas sûr que
parce qu'elles viennent de loin on
renonce complètement à manger des
bananes bon
euh donc je pense que c'est un juste
équilibre à trouver entre d'un côté les
circuits courts si vous voulez quand on
peut faire cultiver des tomates à
proximité moi j'étais maire dans les
cantines scolaires de ma ville j'avais
encouragé évidemment comme à l'Pad ou
ailleurs les productions locales on a
monté des AMAP et cetera donc oui ce
sont des choses qui sont à encourager
après
euh comme je disais tout à l'heure on a
quand même intérêt dans les avantages
comparatifs et sur un certain nombre de
produits à pouvoir échanger au long
cours l'exemple que je donnais tout à
l'heure des avions si ça n'a pas de sens
que chaque pays dans dans le monde se
dotte d'une industrie
aéronautique
bon ça d'ailleurs la ça ça aboutiit une
catastrophe
bon il y aurait des avions de moins
bonne qualité moins sûr avec des
développements technologiques y compris
pour le futur dont on se priverait voilà
donc je pense qu'il faut trouver un un
bon équilibre et il faut trouver un bon
équilibre parce que dans la question du
localisme c'est surtout de la
relocalisation
il faut toujours se poser la question du
prix parce que sur le principe tout le
monde est d'accord tout le monde veut du
made in France mais quand on interroge
nos consommateurs souvent ils veulent du
made in France mais au prix du made in
China je suis un peu caricatural mais
enfin si on dit aux gens attention on
rapatrie tout chez nous mais ça coûte 35
% plus cher le consommateur lorsqu'il se
rend au supermarché il a pas envie de de
payer 35 % en
pluson donc les accords commerciaux ça
sert aussi à ça ça sert à un moment ou
un autre de pouvoir avoir la meilleure
qualité au meilleur prix en ce qui
concerne horizon Europe
oui il y a eu un accord en juillet 2023
entre l'Union européenne et la
Nouvelle-Zélande relatif à la
participation de la Nouvelle-Zélande à
horizon Europe mais il y a aucun lien si
vous voulez avec l'accord de de libre
échange et en ce qui concerne
l'OMC le cœur de la discussion pour nos
amis
américains
c'est en
fait la
question de la capacité d'un organe à
créé sa
jurisprudence les Américains disent nous
on veut bien un
organe première instance mais on
n'aimerait pas d'organe d'appel et on ne
veut pas que ceux qui siègent à l'organ
d'appel développe une
jurisprudence on veut l'application
nette du droit
pour éviter qu'à un moment ou un autre
on se retrouve contraat avec des règles
qui ont été interprétées et pour
lesquelles nous n'avons pas
signé c'est ça le sujet principal pour
nos amis américains dans la question du
du du du règlement des différents
euh sur les odd oui chaque fois qu'on
peut les introduire dans les les les les
accords qu'on signe sein de l'OMC on le
fait la meilleure preuve d'ailleurs
c'est le dernier accord qui a été signé
sur la MC12 sur les subvention à la
pêche illégale on est clairement si vous
voulez dans le cadre du respect des des
des objectifs de développement durable
monsieur le sénateur ho
[Musique]
euh choix géostratégique
ou
euh ils sont fondamentaux parce que
alors ma conviction c'est qu'il faut
tout faire et jusqu'au bout pour essayer
de sauver le
multilatéralisme parce que qui dit
renoncer au
multilatéralisme veut dire rentrer dans
un monde où chacun va agir de manière
unilatérale et donc généralement de
manière
brutale tous ceux qui se sont éloignés
du multilatéralisme dans ces dernières
années ont agit plutôt de manière
brutale et on le voit particulièrement
en ce moment dans les relations
internationales et les accords
commerciaux enfin la la l'absence de
multilatéralisme au niveau commercial ça
veut dire des décisions unilatérales ça
veut dire généralement du
protectionnisme euh et tout cela a un
effet
délétaire sur les prix on voit bien euh
malheureusement euh dans le domaine des
des mesures protectionnistes qui ont pu
être prise par un certain nombre de pays
ces ces dernières années bon et c'est
soit le consommateur soit le
contribuable qui paye la facture à la
fin parce que si l'effort est trop grand
pour le consommateur c'est l'État qui
essaie de compenser mais euh ça pèse sur
le contribuable finalement le
contribuable et le consommateur c'est
souvent la même personne en tout cas
c'est du même porte-monnaie que que que
que sort l'argent quand il s'agit de
payer l'addition à la fin donc moi je
suis pour essayer de sauver le
multilatéralisme euh jusqu'au bout
après on a vu aussi lors de la dernière
pandémie qu'il était dangereux de mettre
tous ses œufs dans le même panier si je
puis me permettre voilà et donc on peut
garder du multilatéralisme tout en étant
dans une
diversification de ces
approvisionnements et c'est là que les
accords sont intéressants parce que on
va aller euh et voilà c'est pas
nécessairement de ce que nous américain
app appelle du frame shoring hein ça
peut être du near shoring c'estàdire euh
localisé en en proximité ou ce qu'on
appelle aussi de la colocalisation
c'està dire je vais essayer de fabriquer
le produit sur différents sites pour
éviter que à un moment ou un autre si
l'un fait l'objet d'un choc qui soit
d'ailleurs sanitaire géopolitique
climatique ou autre euh ce soit
l'ensemble de la production mondiale qui
soit remise en cause donc oui nous avons
un intérêt assigner avec euh les euh
pays de l'azéane des accords nous en
avons d'ailleurs nous sommes en train de
les moderniser je pense notamment à
l'Indonésie je pense notamment au
Vietnam euh voilà avec là aussi des des
des
capacités voilà d'êt dans un rapport
gagnant gagnant et compris d'ailleurs
d'un point de vue d'un point de vue
technologique et dans la stratégie
commerciale si vous voulez de la France
je j'ai j'ai parcouru je vais pas dire
la plupart des pays de l'azéane mais pas
loin euh voilà j'étais j'étais au
Vietnam j'étais en Indonésie j'étais à
Singapour j'étais au
Cambodge voilà je ne suis pas encore
passé en Malaisie ni au Laos mais voilà
je je fais en sorte d'emmener aussi les
entreprises françaises pour faire du
commerce dans ces pays qui représente
dans la zone
Indo-Pacifique des acteurs majeurs et la
zone indopacifique c'est 40 % du
commerce mondial pardon 40 % du du PIB
mondial c'est 60 % du commerce mond
voilà donc c'est c'est c'est
fondamental monsieur le sénateur
François bonau alors
euh sur l'IRA
euh sur l'IRA euh nous continuons les
discussions avec nos amis américains euh
là aussi nous
avons bon du mal si vous voulez à à
aboutir à une solution globale et et
total tellement satisfaisante parce que
nos amis américains eux-mêmes ne peuvent
pas modifier la loi qui a été votée
devant le Congrès donc plus la majorité
pour pour le faire euh nous sommes en
train de travailler à un accord euh sur
les minéraux nous sommes en train de
travailler à un accord sur la
transparence en matière de subvention
publique euh qui permet d'objectiver les
choses et nous continuons euh à
travailler sur
euh
notre propre réponse européenne et
nationale à l'IRA pour faire en sorte
que les investissements restent chez
nous lorsqu'on regarde les chiffres que
j'ai annoncéis tout à l'heure sur
l'attractivité 1750 projets par an le
pays le plus attractif
d'Europe pour l'instant il y a pas eu de
départ massif si vous voulez de projets
français ou de projets mondiaux qui
devaient venir en France vers les
États-Unis ça veut pas dire que il ne
peut pas y en avoir ça veut pas dire que
nous sommes pas attentifs mais mais nous
avons déployé je pense no nos propres
outils le plan France 2030 est un outil
très puissant avec 54 milliards d'euros
rien que pour la France de subvention
pour les projets de décarbonation
d'innovation et cetera euh et nous avons
aussi les les outils européens qui je
pense devrai
convaincre les euh les investisseurs de
rester chez nous euh je dois rajouter
que la détente des marchés sur les prix
de
l'énergie est aussi une réponse si vous
voulez satisfaisante pour l'Europe parce
que certes il y a les subventions ira de
l'autre côté mais là où nous étions
l'année dernière dans une position
extrêmement difficile c'était que
l'énergie à base essentiellement il faut
le dire quand même de pétrole et de gaz
de schist aux États-Unis euh faisait que
les prix énergétiques étaient beaucoup
plus compétitifs euh aux États-Unis que
il ne l'était en Europe y comompris chez
nous lorsque nos centrales nucléaires
étaient à l'arrêt et que le prix de
l'électricité euh euh avait comme le
prix du gaz était multiplié par 3 par
rapport au à la situation euh on va dire
normale voilà donc je je pense que peu
au prou
euh voilà nous avons notre compétitivité
euh ce qui ne veut pas dire que nous ne
devons pas vis-à-vis de nos amis améri
essayer de converger sur notamment entre
amis et entre
alliés des procédures qui ne font pas
une compétition exacerbée de part et
d'autres de l'Atlantique parce que je
pense que si nous nous
faisons ce type de
compétition nous en sortirions l'un et
l'autre perdant par rapport à nos vrais
compétiteurs qui se situe plutôt de
l'autre côté du continent
asiatique
y a-t-il d'autres tuur vas-y Didier oui
juste une autre
question monsieur le ministre vous avez
bien compris que nous n'opposions
pas le commerce à à à tout
autre volonté et il n'était pas du tout
dans nos propos l'idée de dire que nous
n'avions plus la enfin nous devions plus
commercer avec des des pays du monde
ceci étant euh et je crois que c'est un
élément qui est partagé par le
gouvernement on souhaite aujourd'hui
dans les accords commerciaux mettre un
certain nombre de conditionnalités et
faire respecter ces conditionnalités et
à cet égard je voulais avoir votre
sentiment euh sur euh les moyens les
instruments mis en place par la la
commission euh pour suivre ces accords
le cas échant pardon diligentter des
enquêtes et et au final pourquoi pas
imposer des sanctions quand celles-ci
sont prévues euh dans les accords et et
d'autre part j'avais un autre élément
parce qu'on en a pas du tout parlé il y
a un accord qui a été signé avec le
Kenya et j'aurais voulu que vous nous
donniez
votre sentiment sur la stratégie que
nous devons adopter à l'égard de
l'Afrique en matière de commerce euh
international nadjavais aussi il y avait
une question merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre euh j'aurais voulu
quelque chose de très pratique au
pratique en fait sur vous avez annoncé
il y a quelqu temps un plan en fait pour
mieux préparer et accompagner les PME
françaises à
l'international il existe un outil le
volontariat territorial à l'export
j'aimerais savoir comment ça fonctionne
et comment une PME peut-elle le mettre
en place si elle le
souhaite merci merci beaucoup alors
d'abord monsieur le sénateur
marie bien
[Musique]
entendu notre politique au niveau
commerce européen c'est celle de la
réciprocité et d'un certain nombre de
conditionnalités nous sommes ouverts je
l'ai dit mais pas à n'importe quelle
condition pour se
faire nous avons plusieurs outils qui
sont d'abord les clauses miroir dans les
accords commerciaux qui
permettent de poser des conditions à
l'entrée des
produits et les mesures miroir alors les
mesures il faut c'est un peu compliqué
parfois mesures miroir et clause miroire
clause miroire c'est ce qu'on met dans
les accords commerciaux les mesures
miroir c'est ce qu'on met dans la
législation européenne et qui s'impose
du coup à la
fois dans les accords commerciaux mais
également hors accords commerciaux c'est
qu'on a pour être très concret des les
pays avec lesquels on n' pas d'accords
commerciaux par exemple les États-Unis
et la Chine si on prend une mesure
miroir la mesure miroir s'applique quand
même voilà même s'il y a pas d'accords
commerciaux on ne fait pas rentrer dans
l'Union européenne un produit qui ne
respecterait pas si on a une mesure
miroire les normes sanitaires
environnementales et cetera que nous
avons voté
euh et
pour
s'assurer de du respect
de nos propres normes ainsi
que des accords commerciaux
eux-mêmes nous avons mis en place
également un certain nombre
d'outils dont l'instrument antiubvention
dont l'instrument antimesure coeritive
euh enfin antioerition comme on appelle
euh et cetera et ceteraon et nous les
mettons en place voilà et la meilleure
preuve c'est et c'est avec un pays
d'ailleurs avec lequel on n pas d'accord
commercial c'est la Chine ou la
Commission européenne vient de lancer la
fameuse enquête sur les subventions pour
l'industrie des véhicules électriques
voilà qui va donner lieu à un rapport et
potentiellement à des
mesures voilà de protectionnisme
français face à une industrie qui
utiliserait voilà des subventions mass
pour fausser les prix sur le marché donc
nous le faisons en ce qui concerne
l'Afrique oui nous avons un accord de de
partenariat économique que nous avons
signé avec le Kenya qui devrait être je
pense ratifié au niveau du Conseil des
ministes de l'Union européenne dans les
prochaines semaines en tout cas je le
souhaite pour moi
l'Afrique est le continent de la
croissance du 21e siècle
c'est la croissance démographique d'une
part
euh l'Afrique va passer de de 1,5 à plus
de 2,5 milliards d'habitants d'ici à
2050 euh et je dis souvent même s'il n'y
a que 20 % euh de ces 2 milliards et
quelques d'habitants qui ont le niveau
de vie et le pouvoir d'achat d'un
Européen ou d'un nord américain c'est
400 millions de personnes voilà donc si
vous voulez c'est un marché très
important que nous aurions tort de
négliger ce que nous faisons pas au
demeurant puisque nos entreprises
françaises sont
présentes je souhaite là aussi tordre le
coup à une idée qui est répandue par
certains ou par les réseaux sociaux
comme quoi la France ser en déclin en
Afrique que nous serions chassés
d'Afrique nous serions plus les
bienvenus et cetera et
cetera la réalité c'est qu'il y a deux
fois plus d'entreprises françaises en
Afrique qu'il a 10 ans de fois plus il y
a trois fois plus d'investissement
français en Afrique qu'il y a 10 ans bon
donc on a bien pris le chemin de
l'Afrique pas simplement nos grands
groupes comme c'était le cas jusqu'à
présent mais aussi nos PME et je les
accompagne avec lesmion business France
voilà ou BDF international en Afrique
voilà j'ai parcouru une dizaine de de
pays d'Afrique j'étais il y a 10 jours
au Nigéria j'étais encore hier en
Afrique du Sud voilà donc nous sommes
très présent en en Afrique et nous
devons faire de l'Afrique un partenaire
là aussi durable en matière de de
commerce international enfin madame la
sénatrice nadge
av le volontaire territorial à export
alors volontaire territorial export
c'est l'une des mesures phares du plan
export que nous avons lancé le 29 août
dernier vous connaissiez le VI qui était
le volontaire international à l'étranger
un jeune bien formé dont une partie de
la rémunération était prise en charge
par l'État qui était envoyé à l'étranger
pour prospecter les marchés le VTE c'est
le même profil c'est un jeune bien formé
prise en charge à 50 % par l'État dans
un maximum de 12000 € par an qui va être
cette fois-ci placé au sein de
l'entreprise l'idée en fait est la
suivante c'est que souvent les chefs
d'entreprise nous disent
nous on voudrait bien exporter mais vous
comprenez on est déjà occupé une bonne
partie de la journée par notre boulot
sur notre marché local ou national on se
bat pour maintenir notre petite et moyen
entreprise voilà la tête au-dessus de
l'eau on n pas le temps de penser la
stratégie export on n pas nécessairement
les compétences à l'intérieur de
l'entreprise et bien vous n'avez pas le
temps vous n'avez pas les compétences
nous allons vous les donner voilà c'est
l'objet du VTE et je suis sûr que cet
outil aura le même succès que le VI qui
vient de on l'a fait le mois dernier
célébrer son 100000e VI on a
actuellement 11500 VI en poste voilà et
je suis sûr que ça répondra à l'objectif
également que nous sommes fixés c'est de
porter beaucoup plus nos petites et
moyennes entreprises à l'export on a
150000 entreprises exportatrices en
France aujourd'hui c'est mieux que ce
qu'on avait il y a 4 ans où on en a
120000 mais franchement les Italiens en
on 200000 les Allemands 350000 on peut
mieux faire et on c'est l'une des
mesures pour faire baisser notre déficit
commercial avec bien sûr la transition
énergétique qui permettra de moins
importer d'énergie et avec évidemment la
réindustrialisation de la France qui
permettra de reproduire sur le
territoire ce que nous ne produisons pas
aujourd'hui et en le reproduisant sur le
territoire également de l'exporter voilà
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
sénatrices ce que je pouvais vous dire
sur notre politique commercial et sur
les mesures que nous mettons en place
pour voilà porter nos entreprises à
l'export et faire en sorte qu'ensemble
la nation s'enrichisse merci merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre vos
réponses ont été précises et je crois
apprécié on a tenu en 1 he de c'était
l'objectif c'est parfait merci merci à
vous et ateurs vont pouvoir retourner en
séance parce que le débat col terre
continue